大家好 我是全台灣最紅的分析師
紅不紅 有紅啦
變出紅色了沒
因為我的股票
不好意思 漲停
因為我 不好意思
台灣股市創歷史新高
台灣股市在跌破40000點
39000多點的時候
誰敢砸1億的0050
今天已經賺2000多萬了
我不知道賺2200萬還多少
賺太多了 你知道嗎
我很困擾
為什麼你們不跟我一起賺呢
可是我很開心
因為我賺錢我不在乎
我最在乎的是
會員很多人也開始賺錢了
當然之前就很多人賺錢
只是說前陣子真的行情不好
因為我一直有會員
會員一直加入
大家都見證我是台灣奇蹟
我今天的標題叫做
台灣股市創歷史新高
我1.2億的0050
我1.2億的0050是不是要明天出清
我告訴你NO
我今天要告訴你三大重點
第一個 台股創歷史新高
為何收最低
第二個 臉書Muse是什麼
是滑鼠嗎
爆紅 AI股繼續飆嗎
第三個 油價持續回測
美伊會停戰嗎
這三大重點我一次講清楚
大家好 我剛才戴個變色眼鏡
現在最紅的這個眼鏡
哲哲什麼新情勢都喜歡
不然AI時代很容易被人家淘汰
很多分析師會跟你講Muse嗎 會嗎
不會啦
什麼謬論他們都不會講啦
所以你要真的AI時代
不懂AI就被淘汰
每天講飆股 講AI股
基本面講得很厲害
PCB什麼東西
幾成幾成的 講得很厲害
結果AI的趨勢不懂 你相信喔
那個到最後
你要有AI去驅動這些營收
所以你要了解
一個真正懂趨勢的分析師 就是我
台灣股市創歷史新高
我有沒有跟你講
昨天你說哲哲
有摩爾很多老師講50000點 是啊
但是真的如果你有認真看的話
摩爾的老師點數滿厲害的
可是真的有認真看的話
應該是只有哲哲
在39000的時候喊50000點
這個勇氣不一樣
而且我3年內喊10萬點
現在看起來是不是有機會
3年內10萬點真的有機會
台積電那時候5000塊
所以抱緊抱牢
一定要看哲哲的節目
那台灣股市為什麼創歷史新高
為什麼收最低
我今天看一下
我先給你們點點名
要點名一下你們啦 來
點一下你們 看一下
今天台灣50我最多賺2240萬
是不是
哲哲先拍桌
我也有一副
AI眼鏡帥哥 來
宏碁可以滾嗎
今天砸3億 還有7億
哲哲我可以挺你
真的還假的 你這麼多錢
眼鏡好帥 謝謝
特效嗎 我們這不是特效
我們直播很難用特效 知道嗎 來
記憶體被某個白痴亂喊喊下去了
記憶體有下去很多嗎
還好啦
他說不缺啦
這不是啦 跟宏碁沒關係啦
不用擔心 好不好
宏碁自己也下去了
8299群聯
還好啦 群聯還拉起來
但是南亞科殺下去 你看
為什麼我不喜歡買南亞科
因為位階不一樣
你看群聯的位階
你不要看群聯位階好像噴出去了
你看群聯是根本沒漲
他今年2月就已經2500了
就快2500了
現在2185元
所以我覺得他沒漲多少
你看南亞科今年初的時候 多少
今年年初的時候
還在300元這邊 是不是
所以是位階不同
就像為什麼今天我的智原很強
位階不同
智原用週線來看
以前還有400多元
現在200元不到會不會很扯 很便宜
為什麼哲哲這一波績效那麼好
我選低基期
如果剛好前一陣子行情不好的時候
剛好照妖鏡
如果你看的老師每天講漲停板
你相信喔 那你去參加
好不好 你去參加
我也不要去針對誰
因為我常常被人家針對
我知道被針對的痛苦
還有人今天講說
哲哲有網紅講你
你那個會費那麼貴
當然啦 研究團隊要不要錢
這不一樣的 不一樣的
我們研究的
每個人研究的規模水準不一樣
但是我不要去攻擊別人
只要不要太誇張
哲哲都不想回擊也不想提告
我都跟大家講
所以我是笑笑的
告人也累啦
但是當我決定要告下去的時候
我是會很認真告
當然我不是說針對那個網紅
我就覺得都尊重每個人
哲哲怎麼樣 人紅是非多
所以我就平常心
扯遠了 扯遠了
不過當哲哲一告下去
那就不只是花個一年兩年時間了
來 我們來看一下
大盤你看今天上櫃指數也有點開高走低
哲哲怎麼看
我先問大家一件事
你看買0050
都可以賺
都可以賺2200萬
已經20%囉
買了0050都可以賺
接下來我
00981A我看是不是
有些人有聽我的
但是你自己要負責任
00981A是不是要換掉了
因為現在00981A的漲幅
快要輸0050了
不會 接下來要噴了
相信我接下來是國巨的日子 好不好
慢慢來 不緊張
5萬點漲下去不緊張
你們知道今天有個新聞
我請助理傳給我看
直接截圖啦
那個我在Threads上面的截圖
魏哲家跟聯發科的董座抱怨
還是執行長抱怨
我希望我們台積電的股價能贏聯發科
你看一下現在台積電多少錢
多少 2460元
你看一下聯發科多少錢
哲哲 現在聯發科多少錢
今天聯發科最高是5480元
大他一倍多
再講一次
台積電今天多少錢 你們看一下
台積電今天2460元
還沒有到2500 最高2500
聯發科今天多少
今天5180 最高5480元
一個2500 一個5000多 一倍
可是你們知不知道年初的時候
聯發科4月的時候
聯發科1400多元 1430元
台積電快2000元
有哪個分析師告訴你
聯發科會贏什麼
台積電
更恐怖的是我去年
就告訴你台積電會贏聯發科
有印象的舉手
那時候台積電還沒贏聯發科
我去年告訴你台積電會贏聯發科
接下來聯發科後發先至
1400一律做
做到4000多塊
有印象的舉手說有
天分啦
很多人都不知道
哲哲你只會拍桌子而已
不是啊 我連誰贏誰都知道
AI這些趨勢我都知道
你要跟誰比啊
你要找我這種分析師啊
懂不懂
印象 來
那個時候大概只有
等了一兩個月
台積電一開始
先聯發科贏台積電
然後台積電開始拉贏了以後
然後我說OK喔
接下來會後發先至
我還可以預測喔
一開始聯發科贏
我說台積電會贏他
然後我說聯發科接下來會漲 狂漲
有印象的舉手
所以我已經做很多奇蹟
不知道的人只會批評哲哲
哲哲網紅啊 哲哲什麼
全台灣最紅的分析師
我連續三年
助理要做這張圖給我
連續三年
台灣50在最低點的時候
砸幾千萬 砸1億
三年都在最低點的附近
三年 不是一年
你們認識我
是因為有些人是菜鳥而已
我是不是連續三年
都在台灣股市跌幾千點的時候買進
都在最低點附近
魏哲家同框蔡力行
喊股價趕上聯發科有沒有看到
是不是
來 大家看一下有沒有喊有
是不是有講 預告
你看 魏哲家應該要找我當顧問
都是哲哲 好不好
挺哲哲 是不是
我看一下 等一下
有 你看有喔
大家都說有喔
而且我是不是連續三年
都在台股低檔的時候買台灣50
有喔
00981A買28.2
關我什麼事
你買那麼高關我什麼事
我叫你們跌破4萬點的時候
你不要牽拖我
我跟你講一件事
我最討厭這種
叫你買一檔股票
譬如說環球晶500塊
5 600塊我就買了
你偏偏要買在1600怪在我身上
不要扯到我身上
尤其不是我的會員
這樣我壓力很大 我不要
哲哲我們辦公室的妹妹
說他沒看到你戴AI眼鏡
可以再戴一次嗎
不是什麼都AI啦
這是變色眼鏡有沒有
給大家看一下
等一下 摸一下
有沒有 變色有沒有
好玩嗎
好啦 就這樣
變變變 變不見
好啦 就這樣好不好
來 哲哲中秋烤肉嗎
我常常吃烤肉
吃太多烤肉不太好
我常常被我媽媽唸
我現在烤肉我必須去掉焦的皮
太帥了
有 很多人說有
有沒有 有喔
台積電也跟大家講
台積電的股價委屈
可是台積電不可能一下5000
一下5000你要台灣股市10萬點
好不好
哲哲我剛剛有舉手
可以放下來了嗎
還不行 等一下 David
你滿幽默的
魏哲家在聊天室裡面
是誰說先2000吧
結果是 是說誰先2000吧
我那時候好像是說
我記得 我已經忘記整個過程
我記得 我那個趨勢
至少是雖不中亦不遠矣 來
可能是說台積電會先漲
然後到2000可能是聯發科 結果沒有
可是至少趨勢是對的啊 對不對
這個沒錯
所以你看喔
每個人會注視我講的每一句話
至少很準的啦
沒有到100%
也有到9成9整了啦 好不好
哲哲我把身家都ALL IN環球晶了
想像一下 後面早知道去貸款
後面想一下早知道去貸款
你們喔 來 記得一件事
我這個人喔 雖然我推出專案
但是我不缺錢
你們要參加專案
參加我那個007專案
你自己參考
優惠也是很優惠
我要跟你講的是 來 股市有賺有賠
不要到時候不理性 怪哲哲
第二個 尤其不是我會員的
更不要怪我
不是我會員的更不要怪我
那個導播 今天顏色幫我調
要調 調的OK喔
我這邊看還好 沒關係
我很注重顏色
其實我是很不想直播啦
因為我覺得不直播
我燈光可以打更好
真的 好 扯遠了
我剛才說到哪邊
扯遠了 我剛才講什麼
導播我剛才講什麼
你們都忘記了喔
對 賺賠不要怪
不是我會員的 不要怪我
好不好 就算會員大家都要知道
股市有漲有跌
重點是我不會叫你All in
當然有些人是開玩笑的
我把身家都All in環球晶
環球晶可以買
我覺得可以用力買
但我用力買不是叫你要超過五成的
因為股市沒有一定
環球晶你現在要把握住1000塊以下
今天最高到1010
你要想一件事喔
一檔股票
你知道環球晶
我賺了好像180%我都沒走
沒有誇張
所以我看好他是到2000 3000
我再講一次 環球晶我賺
我最多 助理幫我算一下
我最多好像賺到170%
沒有走耶
就是我300萬我可以賺到
那個800萬 誇不誇張
300萬我可以賺到800萬還沒走耶
你3000萬你賺到8000萬你不走嗎
就是我這個瘋子 OK嗎
就要抱得久
再問你們一件事喔
我是7月30號那附近買台灣50
到現在還沒9月30號
沒有兩個月台灣50可以賺2200萬
會等很久嗎
國巨也是如此
行情快來了
你們告訴我39000的時候誰
敲到我的手錶 好痛
等一下重新來
怎麼那麼鬆
好 要敲好一點
你要告訴我行情不好的時候
誰敢給你用力買
包含聯發科 台積電股價之爭
誰告訴你
沒有人啦
連續三年耶
助理 連續三年耶
真的要哭出來耶
你們看一下
連續三年你們看一下
來 這是今年啊
有沒有
我就在這一天最低點
就是39384點
而且我還預告跌破40000點喔
前一天還沒跌破喔
我前幾天預告跌破40000點
老天要送錢給我花我就花
39384點
到現在漲了9217點
在這一天最低點啦
2025年也不遑多讓啊
那一天更屌
對不起 用比較粗俗的字
我有時候覺得我真的沒氣質
我那時候跟你講
就只要追漲停
因為那時候是整個金融海嘯的感覺
關稅之戰嘛
中美貿易戰對全世界課關稅
我說只要他停止關稅
就會追漲停板也沒關係
我還說會漲停板 有沒有印象
我說追漲停板
那時候在18418點
後續漲了30912點
之前逢低買是左側交易買最低點
後面是右側交易
什麼叫右側交易
確定低檔再買
恐怖啊
去年才18000而已耶
現在要50000了
要54000了 三倍了喔
前年 有沒有印象
三年裡面有兩年
都在最低點那一天買進
扯不扯啦
都是公開買台灣50啦
可是最難是去年
我告訴你會漲停板
漲停板再追啊
天啊 我還知道會漲停板
我連漲停板再追
因為那時候深不可測
我三年都可以在最低點附近
尤其兩年是最低點那一天啊
你告訴我誰有這個天賦
你看我第一次節目
你覺得我在胡扯
我覺得你是神棍
沒有 我有這個志向 我有這個志氣
我有這個高傲
告訴你 我不當分析師都沒關係
有賺不完的錢 懂嗎
三年裡面有兩年最低點那一天
有沒有印象
那時候我也穿 第一次穿空手道服
有沒有印象 有沒有
還有哲哲什麼反悔進度
哲哲道歉進度表
那時候還說跌個4 5000點
有沒有印象
台灣股市第一次24000
說等一個又黑又長又粗的長黑K棒
好恐怖喔
然後你看喔
這是前年
這是今年也是最低點
好恐怖喔 都公開買台灣50
都買幾千萬甚至上億喔
那這個是最討厭的
就是這一邊我有買 有賺台灣50
但是我這一天要換掉美債
我這邊要換美債
要把美債換台灣50 你們說不要
我1.74億美債我就放到現在
因為大家說不要
大家說我這樣不守信諾
不守承諾
不然18000放到現在
1.74億早就賺到4億了
我是不是少賺2億
I don't care
我不在乎那個錢
我在乎的是你能不能賺錢
我在乎的是我誠不誠信
OK嗎
我郭哲榮就是誠信為主
所以同業哪個人說我在說謊話
說我騙人家
我照告不誤
就算現在誹謗罪很難成罪
我一定要告
我不在乎花多少錢
你要跟我磨 我也不在乎
你要搞清楚
我2億都敢花的男人
你要搞清楚 我要告訴大家
磨我也沒關係
你要磨到你自己身體不好
某位張姓分析師
張姓分析師不是兩個字的
是三個字的
我不幫他打廣告
身體不好那是您造成的
我也不希望這樣子
誰叫你要跟我磨
我就是這樣子
君子有所為有所不為
三年裡面有兩年低點
你告訴我誰有這個天分
不要每天扯我 攻擊我
有本事就像我一樣
公開操作 也不要事後對帳單
我有本事
真的 不要再攻擊哲哲了
我現在心情是很好
三年裡面有兩年最低點
應該說三年的低點我都抓得很準
一次是左側交易最低點
兩年是最低點
另外一個是確定
我說會有馬上漲停板
確定漲停再追
那追也是18000
後來又漲30000點
你們是不是不相信
來 舉手喊有沒有講
你看有 哲哲是預言家
是不是 有啊 有沒有看到
有沒有 哲哲是預言家
很恐怖
哲哲寶貝今天有沒有剪指甲
我跟你講我就是這麼變態
我還去重訓
來 導播給他看
我每天都剪指甲
我每天都重訓
我最近看我身材也不錯
只是不能脫衣服 不然18禁
來看看 有剪指甲有沒有看到
就是這麼要求自己 知道嗎
有沒有看到 這麼短
只有指甲短
知道嗎 好不好
我就是這麼變態要求自己
真的啦
哲哲應該可以成為股市國寶了吧
稱讚我一下好不好
有 都說有
連續三年有 有沒有看到 好不好
把錢存好 下次大跌跟哲哲一起進
不要啦 那是像哲哲一樣
有錢有時候就進來了 是不是
你1億0050是不是拿美債質押
還是理財型房貸
這我就不多說了
你不用管我的來源
反正第一個我還沒有賣
第二個我1億的0050
現在賺到1.2億了
現在就是1億2200萬了
手指好漂亮 謝謝大家 好不好
OK嗎
有 有 有 你記得啦
網路上也好 分析師也好
秀對帳單
要像哲哲一樣
買當天秀
最好是前一天告訴你要買
不要賺到錢再秀
那都可以P圖
那都可以改
然後預測什麼時候出掉 是不是
我要不是我太紅
我答應主管機關
我不秀對帳單
不然我早就秀出來了
可是你可以查我的券商進出
因為我買的張數很多
那騙不了人
出掉的時候
偷偷出也沒有辦法
那等到我下次要出的時候
怎麼生出來張數讓我出
怎麼生出來股票給我出
所以你不用擔心
我買都買1億
那張數很大 OK嗎
哲哲寶貝
李灝宇明年會站穩老虎先發嗎
那個打擊率都要0.27了
怎麼不會呢 好不好
而且現在消化的那個場合
應該會比較一堆3A的選手出來
他打擊率會更高
扯遠了啦 我幹嘛跟你講棒球
來 這波過前高是48000吧
這波過前高來到48601
銀家
那個寫錯字 是贏家Winner
是3.9萬 4.1萬
大肆進場的有福之人
不就是我
更多的是相信我的人
你想想看喔
如果今天台灣股市來到
今年來到比如說58000 假設
比較難 但不是不可能
那你要57000才進來嗎
不是嘛 就趕快進來
你現在越早進來越
那哲哲 現在50000點了怎麼辦
你到底懂不懂為什麼
你們不要現在看很多的分析師
在給你表演那個叫什麼
聯發科很強 我也有聯發科啊
你要厲害的是
你到底哪個分析師
在1400的時候
一直跟你講聯發科很強
然後賺這一段
你們懂我在說什麼嗎
一個強的分析師
是要像我這樣
在低檔的時候跟你講
我們要用力買進
然後從頭抱到尾
我這一段都沒有在走耶
基本上除非會員要叫我賣股票
不然我沒有要賣耶
我後來出掉的時候
我這邊才買耶
我這邊漲停板跳開以後
我在這邊才買耶
你們都可以作證
然後就一根漲停板
你覺得 哲哲 怎麼買沒告訴你
有人還抱怨的
那些抱怨的憑什麼抱怨
你又不是會員
這個高價股是特Call會員
我特Call會員也不少人 騙不了人
你也可以拉回自己買啊
這兩波我賺得很漂亮
你懂不懂 為什麼 不追高啊
這邊為什麼 這邊要有點追
不一樣 那情況不一樣
一定是要特殊情況
我特殊的情況允許我才要
你看那天爆大量
這邊為什麼不買 傻了啊
早知如此何必當初
你看我們一些預告啊
連續三年都在相對最低點
有兩年是最低點那一天太厲害
有一年告訴你漲停板再追
還真的漲停板
台灣股市漲停板耶
都不會起雞皮疙瘩嗎
那今天為什麼台灣股市有點開高走低
你們知道為什麼嗎
為什麼只漲81點
廢話 你們看一下好不好 你們看一下
你們看一下 為什麼
費半指數突破歷史新高了沒
還沒
那斯達克突破歷史新高了沒 還沒有
那斯達克還沒突破歷史新高
應該沒有 應該沒有突破歷史新高
台灣股市
台灣股市是費半指數加那斯達克的
差不多一半 平均
至少費半指數還沒創新高
助理幫我查一下那斯達克創新高沒
印象中還沒
台灣股市
查一下 我也要順便查
助理幫我查
可是沒創新高也雖不中亦不遠矣
重點是費半指數還沒創新高
這樣知不知道
既然費半指數還沒創新高
投資朋友
台灣股市自己創新高
一定有賣壓
就這樣子而已
可是我講的
你不要覺得48000現在很貴
你可不可以找20000多的股票
說錯了
你可不可以找39000的股票
可以啊 國巨不是39000
國巨有在動嗎
連600元都沒有
環球晶也在差不多
39000 40000出
1000元不到 他從1000元
他從1600跌下去的
不要鬧了好不好
所以選低基期的股票
Understand
我們恭賀簡訊來唸一下
等一下講一下Muse好不好
先那個聯發科
來 導播幫我唸一下
好 9月22禮拜二 今天的簡訊
特Call會員
恭喜2454聯發科
早盤大漲超過9%
差點鎖上漲停 再創歷史新高
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺24%
我持續看好他 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
要漲停耶
聯發科耶
不要等到來的時候
錦上添花 每個分析師都會做
雪中送炭是我的為人啦
知不知道 我的為人啦
OK Understand
來 我們看一下
那斯達克也還沒創新高
助理 我再確認一次
禾伸堂今天進場對嗎
你聽到哪邊的訊息
為什麼我要講
其實哲哲很厲害了
都是預告在前面 真的啦
很強 哪有分析師那麼屌
光是三年都在相對最低點
要嘛就是最低點 要嘛相對最低點
你告訴我哪一個
哪一個分析師做得到 而且公開買進
我那個經濟日報
選股冠軍紀錄保持者
是實實在在的
你告訴我有哪個媒體捧我
現在很多媒體要捧我
但是我很忙啊
因為我要身心靈平衡
很多人都懷疑
哲哲頭髮是不是植髮 沒有
我抗壓性極強
可是我抗壓性極強
一來是我天生身體好
二來是我後天鍛鍊自己
鍛鍊自己不要只是鍛鍊身體 你知道嗎
像黑人陳建州 他鍛鍊身體
但是你要讓身體放鬆
我要鍛鍊我的心靈你知道嗎
這個跟大家講
所以你要找個分析師
真的是發自內心的抵抗任何抗壓性
你看去年很多人亂罵我
同業亂攻擊我
我一一挺過來 更紅了
讓他們知道說
其實攻擊分析師沒有好處
這是我最大的成就感
改變投顧界
真的是改變投顧界
就像我當主委 我當這棟大樓主委
也被人家罵
我這次也是高票當選啊
為什麼 我就講啊
你們都知道我是誰
我在開主委會議的時候
有人一直罵我
還有人罵我說
你們有空可以來我們公司看
導播你可以看一下
地毯顏色啦 為什麼要這個顏色
我說你這樣講
那到底要怎麼決定
這個有什麼好罵的 又沒給我錢
你看我當主委 我是做義工
我說這棟大樓再不處理的話
會爛掉啊 我不是開玩笑
我很務實主義者
被人家罵一罵以後
結果我得最高票
以前的那個調整管理費啊
大概只有六成
大概全部都不通過
我跟他們講是投資 他們就認同
八成以上支持我
然後那個管委會投票
我超過一半 有五個人競選
我超過一半人投我當委員
為什麼 人在做天在看
我都是這樣子的
我也沒有拿錢
而且重點是我還常常給那些
總幹事他們
就是有些人 就是大家
我還送給那些管理員 很辛苦啊
遇到管理員我都會送禮
我平常不送禮喔
我跟你說真的 我是那種
我是那種 反而我覺得
比較辛苦工作的
一些比較辛苦 打掃的阿桑啊
我反而會送禮 我是這種人
我覺得一個人成功不是
我只是運氣比較好
我爸媽把我生得比較聰明一點
然後我比一般人努力一點
然後這個行情
遇到台積電這個AI大行情
我剛好遇到
2012年的時候
台積電真的還好啦 你懂不懂
那時候1000磅的大猩猩
他稱讚Intel跟三星
那時候還不知道台積電那麼厲害
所以生逢其時啊
台積電員工也是一樣
2012年之前跟2012年之後差很多
自從夜鷹計畫
這些我都如數家珍
我要講的是說
我運氣很好 可是人在做天在看
我要講的是人在做天在看
我有時候是一個責任
你懂不懂 責任啦
我們這種大樓2000多人
我做這些事情
也是 你們也是我的責任啦
我也可以買小型股 每天漲停板
我可以買禾伸堂 信昌電
你信不信我可以讓他每天拉漲停板
我一堆會員身價好幾億啊
幾十億都有啊
隨便拉
但是我不想做這種事 你知道嗎
我想讓你知道
從客觀 主觀上面看到
我喊水會結凍
我不要喊小型股
不要讓你有一點點爭議 你知道嗎
這個跟大家講 好不好
哲哲 AI只是開始
記憶體怎麼了 沒有怎麼了
那是你的記憶體啊
南亞科沒什麼 好不好
TVBS說
哲哲投資長0050賺2000億喔
真的還假的 打錯字是不是
TVBS最近也很喜歡我的新聞
來 我看一下 賺2000億
真的嗎 趕快截圖
助理給我看一下
哲哲天生盤感
主委要選有錢的
很累 真的很累 還要被人家罵
可是幸好罵我的人是少數
我都一句話 我的邏輯很強
我說你要批評我
我用你的標準來看你做事情
你一件事都做不了 你信不信 真的
哲哲大肌肌國巨
我最近一直在練
我一直要把我的肩膀練起來
我一直在想
其實我很追求完美
我一直在想要不要打類固醇
告訴我自己又不要
因為我知道很多明星
或很多人打類固醇
因為我的肌肉長很快
但是我又不想
因為打了類固醇會有害身體
但是肌肉會變很大
所以跟自己對話很重要
你知道嗎 來
哲哲大哥哥
我把阿嬤房子換了快300張合晶
你很不孝 阿嬤房子換的
當然都開玩笑的 來
這是最佳的投資長
大家跟著買美債 都虧錢
哲哲就叫大家賣掉換0050
把虧的錢賺回來
這麼久了 哲哲美債虧錢 對啊
其實你講到我的痛苦
其實那時候你們虧錢的時候
我是有點難過的
可是我有給你心生妙計
趕快停損換0050
現在0050又突破歷史新高了
所以換句話說
基本上你任何時刻買0050都是賺錢的
可是我美債是賠錢的
真的啦 比誠信沒有人贏得了我
真的人在做天在看
好不好 我們開始要講股票
不要講這個難過的事
不會啦 其實我不會
就是因為這樣
所以其實公司很多人願意跟著哲哲
我常常一句話
我說你不要跟我計較這些錢
說別家別家 怎麼可能
我說以前 像比如說業務的制度
我們有些業務制度
以前別家都沒有底薪的
是摩爾第一家給底薪的
這個也可以去打聽
我說我們沒在計較錢的
講一次他們就聽得懂 真的啦
薪水最高一定是摩爾投顧
扯遠了
當然我還是希望各個業界一起好
我覺得不錯啊
大家一起給薪水不是很好嗎
所以我沒有要攻擊同業
你們不覺得大家把餅一起做大很好
所以不一定要覺得討厭哲哲
來啦 精材拉起來啦
怎麼看 我就說精材的大戶
精材裡面的大戶很厲害啦
我也不敢違逆啦
我看起來就很恐怖
說老實話我也最近沒什麼買啦
我就一直抱著 一直抱著 一直抱著
一直抱著 抱著 抱著
所以精材是比較舊會員的人比較開心
所以我就說你趕快加入我的行列比較快
因為有時候我覺得那個時間會買
過一段時間就不會
就像聯發科
像5000元以上 我基本上就不買了
我就不喜歡追高 能怎麼辦
可是就是因為我不追高
今年績效很好啊
你國巨再怎麼罵我 我看一看
原來有人580 590
自己買然後怪我 莫名其妙
我從來沒有買超過600塊以上
然後跌個10%怪我 那個不要看我
不要看我的節目
不要 彼此不要玷污彼此 真的
我都不追高啊 國巨600元以上
你去找別的老師 不要找我
是不是 一樣嘛 我就不追高嘛
所以精材那時候
你錯過精材的買點
你們記不記得精材那時候
每天有人罵我
哲哲你不講精材
哲哲不講聯發科
有沒有 就跟現在國巨一樣
你怎麼不講國巨 怎麼不講環球晶
莫名其妙
我今年績效 是我當分析師20年來
績效最屌 最好
我又講這個字眼了
真的很討厭
最好 最棒 最美妙的績效
今年績效最好啊 你還不來找我
從年初旺到現在9月
我看要旺到年底了 你看
真的很厲害
連續三年都在最低點附近
然後買進
連兩年就是最低點那一天
然後公開買進台灣50
我對你還不夠好
這不是天分這是什麼
很多人說哲哲只是找拉回就買
不是耶 那是天賦耶
然後關稅沒有人抓到低點
我說等漲停板再說
等漲1000點再說
你們看不懂我跟別人盤感差很多
不是差一點點 是差一大截
恭喜3374精材股價開高走高
直接衝上漲停板
我們買進到現在最高已經大賺150%
我很變態 150%還沒走
我這是要讓你買房子用的
你懂不懂
現在就有新聞出來了
說現在股市的資金怎麼樣
棄房入股了
早就跟你講了 現在買房子是有得住
你要養老婆 你要養小三
你要養男朋友 你要養牛郎
你再住啦 不要空房子啦 懂不懂
先蹲後跳 9月股民信心回升
有沒有 市場棄房轉股
早就跟你講了 接下來還是一樣
所以為什麼我當這邊主委跟他們講
他們說得動
以後台灣的房子喔
跟日本一樣
比較偏遠鄉下的房子賣不掉
甚至可能免費賣
就算台北市也是如此
你懂不懂
譬如我們這個地點是精華地段
但是管理不好 就是沒價值
懂嗎 所以要投資
以後房子就是這樣子
所以以後房子越來越難漲
以後一坪
現在台北市一坪有200萬很正常
以後到300萬 那為什麼
就像滷肉飯以前不到10塊錢
現在可以到50塊錢一樣
只是跟著通貨膨脹漲
但是他主動漲價的力道沒有了
他是被動漲價
配合通貨膨脹
建材要漲了 人工要漲了
所以我成本得墊上去
我售價得要墊高
所以一坪100萬變成200萬
200萬變成300萬
但是不會像以前 哇 我有漲價空間
因為我也不想買
因為沒有買的人那麼多
你要記得這個邏輯
可是股市漲的速度會很快
因為取決於AI發展的速度
等一下我再講Muse 要趕快講
棄房買股有沒有看到
棄房轉股有沒有看到
買房意願降到38.6% 還會降更低喔
賣房意願也低了
其實我是覺得你要賣是可以賣啦
不要低啦 什麼意思
你們有些人不想賣房子
是覺得房子不好賣就不賣啦
多的房子該賣就賣
你以後會謝謝我
就算不賣 你可以用理財型房貸好不好
可是只要講到貸款這件事
來 看一下
本資料僅供參考
不要牽拖哲哲 好不好
我自己操作 我會很厲害賺錢
我怎麼知道你怎麼操作 是不是
現在都沒有照做
或者是沒來幾天怪我
千萬別 好不好
你不缺哲哲
哲哲也不缺會員
好不好 真的 OK嗎
來啦 中秋有沒有看到
007專案
這個還是我自己做的
我嫌我們設計美編比較慢
他最後幫我改一下
007有沒有看到 標靶
砰砰砰 快狠準
射到每一支飆股
然後告訴哲哲 你真是棒
James 棒
007不是James Bond嗎
射中月亮 射中標靶
007專案 優惠啦
以前都是199啊 777專案啊
精彩539
這個數字應該最小的一次吧
自己參考
要不要參加隨便你 好不好
我跟你講了 從精材的例子
現在如果是這一兩個月
這一個月參加的會員
沒有精材 絕對沒有精材 不夠精彩
為什麼 我就不想追高
所以我再講一件事
股票錯過了我就不買了
我跟你講 國巨800元以上
基本上我絕對不再買
我再講一次 基本上我絕對不再買
國巨到800元
你告訴我 哲哲 漲到1200了
800到1200的 我跟你講
你上不了車啦
就算800到1600我也不上車啦
我就是這樣子
就算欣興今天1000多塊怎麼樣
我300多塊就賣掉
那又怎麼樣
可是我70塊買 我100多塊買
100多塊跌到70塊 我還是在買
懂嗎 我一直抱著
我到300多塊
賺一倍多還不行喔
300到1000塊以上我沒賺到 沒有錯
I don't care
因為我一堆飆股賺好幾倍
漲上去我就不追了
精材我漲上去就不追
可是我可以死抱活抱
漲上去我就不追
如果是我自己操作我會追
順勢而為啊
你操作我不會追 為什麼
你們的心態跟我心態不一樣
就算你是我的會員
你也沒辦法百分之百心態像我一樣
我太了解粉絲會員的想法了
所以我不要到時候
大家怪來怪去 我都不要
願者上鉤
你認同我 你覺得我是姜太公
大家合作 不是就不要
懂不懂 所以精材這個股票
我不會追了
我不會追了 我這個月我也沒再買
你們都知道
可是舊粉絲一堆買一堆
我也不買 你看之前洗盤洗多久
我不買
所以一樣啊 007專案買的股票
有可能之後就不買了
有可能環球晶1000元以上我也不買
1000元以下我買到脫皮你知道嗎
買得很用力你知不知道
買得很用力 買的繭 我有點繭
重訓 知道嗎 這個跟大家講
好啦 扯遠了
是賺2000萬
寫2000億是不是
本來是寫2000億是不是
他寫錯了是不是
應該被人家改錯了
賺近2000萬
請寫信給TVBS
0050這波猛 哲哲賺近2000萬
已經賺了2000萬了 好不好
看台股50000點
是時間問題有沒有看到 厲不厲害
0050這波猛
最猛哲哲 0050真的是
元大真的是要 廣告費要給我
但是我不收啦 你給我也不要
這個小錢 我不要為了拿小錢
然後誠信毀掉 我就是這樣
不收業配 不好意思
你們所有的ETF都不用打動我
你們可以推薦我
像00662那時候我說不錯吧
我說你們還是可以買00662
你們不要只買台灣的台灣50
你可以買那斯達克的台灣50
就是那斯達克的50
你懂嗎 那種感覺
權值股一樣 懂我的意思嗎 好不好
昨天可能是寫2000億 今天改了
這個跟大家講
所以我們來看一下
看一下大家的互動
想跟哲哲
哲哲每天用AI
怎麼保養眼睛的
我也不知道 我度數還蠻深的
可是老了以後沒有老花 蠻奇怪的
我一直以為我眼睛很差 好不好
哲哲有跟TVBS業配嗎
當然沒有 你在說什麼
一堆媒體記者
你有沒有想一件事
我要業配 我要花很多錢
我有時候一天十幾個新聞
你到底有沒有搜尋過郭哲榮
基本上我每週都有幾十則新聞
哲哲突然講得很激動的時候
突然冷靜下來表情真的很逗 真的嗎
血壓升高了 突然頭暈了
就會靜下來
經過今天大漲
堅定我相信哲哲的決心
你一定要漲才相信我 太遜了吧
哲哲可以看聯電嗎
聯電就是要噴出去了
我還記得以前聯電不到100元
一直被人家罵
聯電要噴出去了
我已經下好離手
哲哲就是真男人 重感情
很少像哲哲這麼重感情的男人
太重感情也不好
所以我交朋友也是要交重感情的
好不好 來
5347世界先進有沒有看到 一路漲
我還是喜歡世界先進好不好
這看起來漲真的
我昨天不是說3035智原
其實漲怪怪的嗎 有說嗎
今天ASIC題材都漲了 為什麼
因為大家覺得是專門的特製用的
怎麼樣 的AI
創意什麼時候變8300了 好恐怖
ASIC題材有沒有看到
這個很誇張 直接跳空漲停板
所以智原還算遜掉
所以現在龍頭是怎麼樣
是創意的 好不好
股價龍頭本來就是創意
創意就是之一
但是我講的是現在的趨勢
所以智原還算老二的
那比較吃虧
老二 老三比較吃虧 好不好
我們來看一下智原的
有沒有智原簡訊我們看一下
等一下講一下Muse
等一下一定要講
先唸一下智原
幫我念一下 來
好 9月22號禮拜二 今天的簡訊
恭喜3035智原
股價一度漲停 創2個多月新高
臉書Muse帶動矽智財需求
我持續看好他 手上持股抱好抱牢
恭喜大家賺大錢了
沒關係 給我
有沒有看到
臉書Muse對不對
帶動矽智財嘛 這些需求
先從臉書好了
有空再講那些Muse的矽智財 來
最近在漲這個行情喔
來 我還是要強調一件事
大盤快創新高
大盤已經創新高了 有沒有
櫃買還差一大截
這就是你的獲利空間
大盤已經創新高
大盤在這邊 櫃買在這邊
這個就是你的獲利空間
記得我這件事情好不好
現在你不覺得我都預測在前面嗎 來
來 你看這三個
Meta Muse帶旺CPU行情
我有稍微理解一下
它這個趨勢不一樣
第一個 它密碼理論上
不會去讀取你的密碼
就不會有一些危機了
就不會利用你的密碼
第二個為什麼 它也是Agent AI
那以前Agent AI
有些也可以在手機用
但是他手機用現在用得比較順
Muse這個軟體喔
可以幫你代訂行程
哲哲那怎麼紅的
背景代辦 它以前是手機用以後
專供你的APP
比如說Trip.com APP
哲哲 Agoda
訂房嘛 訂機票嘛
不是 你用APP
因為APP它是在封閉的程式裡面
IPhone裡面封閉程式
不是 是手機指揮上面的雲端
雲端怎麼樣 手機變成遙控器
以前是手機在跑 很麻煩
手機在雲端跑有什麼好處
雲端你在跑你的頁面
懂不懂 我不要跑APP
我跑Trip.com 我跑Agoda
我不要跑它的APP程式
我去跑網頁程式
懂不懂 我用跑網頁
OK嗎 就比較不容易被擋了
OK嗎 IE的安全度
這個網頁的安全性比較沒那麼高
所以跑起來會比較順 你懂不懂
所以CPU市場需求成長
然後發現很好用
你懂不懂我的意思 OK嗎
那這些東西怎麼樣
你就要買晶片啊 有沒有
Meta為它第二大客戶 有沒有看到
所以單日大漲10% 有沒有看到 AMD
所以漲真的 有沒有看到
AMD又拉起來了
是不是 這整個市場都OK了
晶片市場又拉起來了
還有矽智財的市場
ARM的市場 有沒有 這些跟那個
跟那個智原又有間接的相關
這樣懂不懂
所以這就是為什麼矽智財漲起來了
好 OK嗎
你看 iOS下載量有沒有看到
ChatGPT一開始才130萬
Muse已經180萬了
所以AI進步很快
這跟2000年網際網路
真的上網的人有多少
真的重度使用的有多少
真的手機廣泛運用是iPhone產生
其實是宏達電
宏達電真的是先驅
宏達電以前是幫O2 電信代工
我以前還看過
以前叫做PDA
後來PDA 就是你的個人助理
是Personal PDA
Digital Assistant PDA
PDA加手機
以前PDA還可以照相
PDA加通訊就變成智慧型手機了
那還不是夠智慧 再加上APP
賈伯斯重新定義智慧手機 OK嗎
那還要一段時間
從2000年網路泡沫
到2007年 2008年的iPhone發表
你不覺得我很老嗎 如數家珍
這就是投資30年的好事
當分析師20年的好處
你不選我要選誰 你不要看我年輕
同樣的錢你不選最紅的你要找誰
要選就選最紅的 你家有沒有
如數家珍 這要天分加重度閱讀
我非常喜歡看
什麼籃球 棒球都看
我是資訊愛好者
沒有看到資訊
我會很不開心你知道嗎
Netflix前幾名
最近亞馬遜紅什麼
Apple訂閱影片紅什麼
什麼礙的迫降 阻礙的礙
我都會稍微看一下
好看我就繼續看下去
我花非常多時間在搜尋新資訊
不是有些很多財新網紅是
最近我稍微看一下 我照抄人家的
沒有 我是真的很認真去了解
重點是你看
這種東西跟網路泡沫差很多
網路泡沫它整個成熟要很久
要花個7 8年的時間
不是啦 你看下載都越來越快
因為現在已經有網路架構了 你懂不懂
差很多
那AI代理模式就是我剛才講的 好不好
他在雲端虛擬電腦
以前不是
我要幫你開網頁 用手機幫你開
沒有 在雲端幫你做事情比較快
他更聰明 繞過執行 OK嗎
在雲端做 不在你的手機做
好不好 OK嗎
執行工作需要CPU嘛
所以速度影響GPU
所以這些都需要 OK嗎
壓住AI的應用擴大運算
這個我不是都講了嗎
我就說90度運算
我就說我看到趨勢
那你跟我講接下來會有什麼發展
我很難講每個細項
但是我看到趨勢是發展越來越快
趨勢是發展越來越快
半年一次一個新的版本
後來變兩三個月
現在變一個月一個版本有沒有
所以你要相信 好不好
可是亞馬遜有限制Muse的購物
有些會限制 但有些還是會有
好不好 OK嗎
延伸客製化的晶片
追求更高效率有沒有
這些延伸題材有沒有
所以ASIC的創意會漲
你看我做這些這麼漂亮的字
你有沒有發現到
別人做的一般的AI圖片
都是比較藍藍的 深深的顏色有沒有
我不是
哲哲是庭院深深深幾許 什麼意思
詩情畫意的男人 扯遠了
好了 幾分鐘
47要趕快
所以這樣懂Muse嗎
大概懂就好了
就是他的下載量很快
那大家覺得AI是真的
還有一個什麼原因
還有啦 很多人說漲這個原因
不是啦 真正漲是什麼
沒有升息 升息機率降低了
你看 伊朗的停戰條件
4月有十點方案
承認伊朗的濃縮鈾權利
美國怎麼會答應
所以這次他都沒有提到
要賠償伊朗戰爭損失
你覺得美國有可能賠償伊朗嗎
除非美國戰敗
美國怎麼可能
美國死也不會承認自己戰敗
你這不是叫他政治自殺嗎
這次都沒有提了
所以代表他這次都找務實的要求
停止對伊朗領土攻擊 有沒有看到
這個有機會
保證不再侵略伊朗
怎麼可能會保證
我又不是輸了 是不是
所以這一次的要求完全合理
他就說以後我要掌控海峽
現在沒有說要掌控海峽
你履行條件後我才重開海峽
沒有說以後海峽是誰的 有沒有看到
川普不排除會晤伊朗總統
但見伊朗總統沒啥用
他們是軍方領導人比較實在
所以布蘭特原油殺下去
這才是重點
美國10年期公債殖利率也下滑
有沒有看到 重新跌破5%
這是重點
這是兩個重點 只知其一不知其二
股市沒辦法噴
你的分析師有沒有講這個
每天我漲停板 我又什麼漲了
CPO強 我的CPO
矽智財強 我的矽智財
你相信喔 剛好你賠錢
所以007專案你要不要隨便你好不好
我們今天就是這麼強
中秋007 好不好
過了中秋就沒這個專案 好不好
過了這個村就沒這個店了
好不好 OK嗎 趕快來看一下
智原有沒有 拉上去
3374精材 漲停板
2454聯發科 有沒有看到
今天也一度快漲停
夭壽喔 開玩笑 聯發科耶
讓大象也跳舞 還有誰
還有6488環球晶
今天也一度大漲 1000元喔
今天一度1000元喔
5483 我說1000元以下
一個200元以下的中美晶
也要把握住喔
現在幾分
要結束了 飆股一堆講不完
記憶體不要擔心好不好
記憶體最該擔心的只是他位階高
不然其實不用擔心
所以群聯就拉起來
一堆位階低的股票 國巨
3年10萬點啦 現在有沒有感覺
哲哲1億賺了
2個月不到賺了2200多萬
是不是2280萬 我不知道
2200多萬 那個尾數送給大家
我沒有在乎
反正賺的錢我要去捐救護車
好不好 OK嗎
所以明年又第三台
年底我今天又繳了
好像100多萬的救護車車款
因為他要分三期
12月你就看到我捐救護車的影片
最晚一月出來
反正12月有救護車的影片 好不好
理論上會有
12月我會捐給桃園市政府
下一次 不要說我不公平
下一次我會捐給南部的縣市 好不好
北部也捐 南部也捐
最好藍綠白 藍綠都捐好不好
這樣才公平好不好
不然談政治傷感情
下一次我會捐 希望回饋社會
希望你跟哲哲一樣
賺到錢 而且回饋社會
像我們一樣 越賺越多
好不好 是真的
哲哲打從心底希望大家賺錢
希望你能感受到我的熱情
好不好 連續三年都在最低點的時候買進
最低點附近 兩年是最低點那一天
中秋007專案
錯過了智原
今天是快漲停嘛 是不是
已經忘記了
聯發科快漲停
錯過了精材漲停
看起來要邁向500 600 700
怎麼辦
你不能錯過中秋007專案
飆股一個接一個
哲哲 真是棒 James Bond
007這個數字那麼小
專案我認為相對很優惠
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
台灣股市創歷史新高
我0050賺錢了
我在恐怖的時候給大家信心
你為什麼不跟我一起進場
下次10萬點 你會不會後悔
我相信你一定會後悔
如果你會後悔的話
如果你覺得你會後悔的話
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
0800來來幫您幫我
還有加入我的LINE私訊我
我的LINE很簡單
上面有藍盾牌 白勾勾
就是官方認證的LINE
加入LINE以後 說哲哲 會費多少
哲哲 怎麼幫我賺錢
我竭盡所能來幫你賺大錢
謝謝各位 Byebye